so before this video starts there are a
couple of people that i actually a few
people that i wanted to thank
for the event first of all brother
absolutely of course
uh for coming up to columbus to give
such an amazing talk
then i want to thank my msa board
particularly
nida tufani and my co-chair samashire
then i wanted to thank
brother abdullah and lucy for
recommending such a good speaker from
the muslim debate initiative
next i wanted to talk about the events
that happened prior to
the recording of the video
so
first we played one of vedu vids
videos
um about why uh
muslims
interpret the quran very very
selectively
and then we had brother us allah's
response to that video which was like a
parody of that one
then we brought brother
up and asked him
why he created that video and why he has
this youtube channel there in the first
place
um you guys
this is already on his youtube channel
you guys are pretty familiar with that
then we broke for malcolm after we broke
from
we brought us brother assad allah back
up
and we talked about the reasons why he
became muslim
among the reasons which at least i found
interesting was
his
his previous family was also muslim and
this gave him an emotional
push to make the decision to become
muslim as well
uh after which i got into character and
i told him that
that that his decision was wrong
right even though i'm muslim i just
adopted this one character so you'll see
that throughout the video i keep on
poking him i try to challenge him
i try to
make fun of him a little bit
just to keep it like lively try to keep
it fun
and then afterwards
oh yeah by the way the first question is
why did the prophet marry a
nine-year-old so
keeping all that in context
enjoy
their parents
had to go through very similar
circumstances you know the whole the
whole age thing you know we're talking
about maturity now at 18 are up this is
really very recent it's only past 100
years or so
okay so our grandparents
didn't understand this concept very well
they they formed that love while they
were in the relationship they didn't
just suddenly jump into it
you know from that perspective
um
so this is a very recent thing
for us and um
yeah didn't have any options back then
so this whole idea that oh because this
this person is 20 years or 30 years old
they didn't care the guy's alive
that's what they want i'm serious right
the guy's alive he's got money he hasn't
been killed yet
you know i mean that was a great catch
back then
i thought
i'm serious
right uh you don't think you think
that's nonsense but that's really what
they were worried about
you know the thing that they were oldest
is kind of handsome you know is he is he
idiot is he a good talker he didn't care
anyways so i got another question for
you about islam and why i don't like it
okay go ahead okay
question answered by the way at the end
if you guys want to hold your questions
we'll go at it don't worry
so i think i'm not stupid okay i'm smart
so
you have this life okay yeah it's finite
you can do as many sins as you want in
this life and it's gonna be fine right
yeah right okay but is hell finite
no or is it in like or is it everlasting
it's a blaster then how does that make
sense
what are you talking about i'm smart
okay so what are you saying you're
saying that there's a problem with the
turtle hellfire for a finite amount of
sins yep okay well what if i told you
that in islam that you're in hellfire
forever is because your sin is forever
is committed continuously over and over
and over and over again
life is finite okay so anybody can read
for me uh quran
surah 6 ayah 27-28
please where's the scene
i'll do this
translation preferably for those who do
not speak arabic you said 27 and 28
please i just want to uh
have somebody read that real quick and
i'll explain it so what to do again sort
of six i had 27 to 28. if you could but
see when they are made to stand before
the fire and we'll say oh with that we
uh with that we could be returned
brackets to the life on earth bracket
and not deny the signs of our lord and
be among the believers
but what they concealed before them has
bracket now bracket appeared to them and
even if they were returned they would
return to that which they were forbidden
and indeed they are liars okay so
there's a scene here where somebody's
going he's facing the hellfire and he
asked allah hey i'm paraphrasing he's
saying look i feel bad for what i did
can you send me back so i can do some
good deeds and come and get an agenda
and allah says i know for a fact that
when you go back
you're gonna do the exact same thing
so you're lying
now what does this mean
well there are numerous passages in the
quran that talk about tufar and what
happens when they're in hellfire and
allah calls him a certain name or he
says something about them every single
time he says one thing about them he
says they're arrogant
he also says hell fire is for the
arrogance
so what does this mean he's talking
specifically to individuals
who know that allah exists
who know what allah wants
who know that they shouldn't be doing
certain things but regardless of that
they refuse to submit
because of their arrogance they refuse
even if they're standing before the
hellfire the only reason they want to
get out is not because they want to
submit to the truth or to god's guidance
it's because they do not
they just don't want to deal with they
want to deal with the punishment
okay
so they continuously commit the sin of
not wanting to submit to god
so their sin is eternal not in quality
but also in quantity
they literally refuse that's why when
allah calls out calls them out he's
saying to them you are lying i know for
a fact that you're making an excuse
you don't actually want to repent
and that's why he keeps them there allah
is not keeping them there
it's their pride that's keeping them
there
now there's an interesting story um
so actually before we get into that
there are other passages the same
conversation occurs and in fact when
these people these these particular
people are being dragged into the
hellfire
they're repeating something
everybody knows what that is
they said we did nothing wrong
we did nothing wrong
they're telling allah
the omniscient
the one who knows everything
the one who created morality
they're telling him that he's wrong
okay
they're not even admitting they're not
admitting that they've done anything
they literally think they are perfect
they are sinless
that is the type of arrogance that we're
discussing here
now um
some may record and say well you know
it's just any disbeliever that's being
thrown in hell for that's not
necessarily true he believes
what was he called when he refused to
submit
to allah's command
he became one of the disbelievers
he knows allah exists it's not like he
doesn't know i mean of course he was he
was he was
one of the closest beings to allah
and yet he is called a catholic
interesting right and there's a lovely
story that my sheikh told me i don't
know if it's canonical or anything like
this but uh i think it's derived from
hadith but it's not it's not exactly
what it is
it may have been just something that was
passed down by scholars but
anyway so this beautiful story about
three people who were sent to hellfire
and so what the first person came in
and um allah commanded him to be thrown
into the hellfire so the angels had to
drag him in he was kicking and screaming
saying i didn't do anything wrong they
threw him in second person came in
and uh allah commanded him to be thrown
to hellfire
and the angels were about to take him
and he said no
i'll go in myself so he walked in and as
he was about to walk into the hellfire
he turns around he looks at allah and
then he puts himself in the hellfire
third person comes in and allah says
you know he commands him to be thrown
into hellfire
this man says i don't want to be thrown
in he runs into the hellfire
okay so then allah asked all three of
them what they did
he goes the first one he says why were
you kicking and screaming and saying you
did nothing wrong and the man repeated
himself said i did nothing wrong
and allah says you are arrogant you will
remain here for all of eternity
he goes to the second man he says why
did you walk in and as you were walking
you turned behind to look at me
and he said as i was walking in i turned
around hoping that he would have mercy
on me
and allah said because you had that hope
in me i will put you in the first place
of general the first level of jennifer
took him out of hell fire then he went
to the third man he said why did you run
he said for the first time in my life i
wanted to do as you asked
he said because of that sacrifice
because you were willing to condemn
yourself for interpreting i will put you
in the highest level of gender
so
um the story always kind of affected me
quite a bit
um
and it shows that you know
allah's mercy is for everyone but when
we're talking about mercy people don't
really understand what mercy is they
think mercy is just forgiving people
regardless of the fact that they've done
wrong that's the gist of it but there's
more to mercy than that mercy requires
repentance
mercy requires that the person who has
done the wrong
actually feels like they've done wrong
that they're looking for that mercy
but if they believe they don't do they
don't need mercy if they believe they've
done nothing wrong
how can they receive that and let me
give it to you like this
if you're a judge and somebody comes up
to you they murdered somebody and they
admitted to murdering somebody and you
say
you know how do you feel do you regret
your decision they said no i do it again
are you going to let them back on the
street
that would be stupid
because that's like they're taking
advantage of you
they want you just to let them go regard
that's not mercy that's stupidity
okay that has nothing to do with mercy
because even the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him you know you would say a
parent's love
for their child is one of the highest
forms of mercy but he said even if
fatima my daughter
had stolen something i would have her
hand cut
right
that's hard
no listen
because the justice remember listen
just because you feel partial to someone
okay it does not necessitate that you
have to get rid of your principles right
mercy is not just about
forgiveness it's about having is it's
about somebody reciprocating
that is about accepting that mercy
it's about understanding what justice is
it's about understanding so many other
things
and when we say that allah has to
forgive everyone
he has to because he's all merciful
you don't understand allah's mercy
you do not understand allah's mercy
how can you have mercy let it's not
mercy
to just forgive any just to say oh you
can do whatever you want it's okay just
you know
i'll send you to jenna anyway you are
devaluing the people who didn't do
anything the people who actually tried
what how is that being merciful to them
why did they have to go through so many
struggles and tests to prove
themselves
but this person he can murder and
slaughter and do whatever he wants you
know reject allah reject his purpose in
life reject the whole
origin of morality itself
and just get away with
what's the purpose
of even bothering to follow god then but
i'm a nice person
are you
my mom says okay
so we're talking about okay so if you
want to if you want to argue
how can i get hurt i didn't get like
well god's not hurt at all jannah and
and johanna are not for allah that's
nonsense i mean he doesn't need that
but you know if you're going to deny
your purpose you're going to deny the
very
the very being that gave you morality
itself
um if you're going to
uh
part of my you know
bluntness here if you're going to give
the you know the metaphorical middle
finger
to to this being when you meet him
knowing that where your destination is
can you really feel any sympathy for
this person
like i mean come on
like who who in their right mind and if
they're insane of course they're excused
but who in their right mind as a same
person
would do that standing in hell near
hellfire facing your creator and saying
i didn't do anything wrong
that person doesn't deserve sympathy
screw that man
seriously
who cares
what what person what how arrogant do
you have to be
i have no mercy i have no sympathy for
that person i don't understand why you
do
because my mom told me i'm a nice person
that's nice
so it's important part of my part of my
forwardness but honestly i feel so
i feel intellectually insulting
that anyone would ask me
why this person deserves to be in
hellfire for eternity when they've made
that decision themselves
i don't care
go ahead
your prophet
drank
camel pee
okay
yeah so you're talking about this
particular i don't think you drank it as
a hadith but okay so in this hadith okay
uh the hadith referred i'm gonna pull it
up real quick yeah
the hadith referred to by the questioner
is
uh in which it says that some people
came to medina and fell asleep the
prophet peace and blessings of allah be
upon him
told them to drink the milk and urine of
camels and they recovered and grew fat
okay isn't camel
it's also in bukhari and muslims so why
is this a problem too because camel p is
disgusting what kind of all right so
let's say let's assume so the scholars
approach this in two different ways so
let's assume for the sake of argument
okay that it's
which generally it is today we know that
if you drink camel urine
it's not exactly a good thing to do
uh it's just not hygienic to drink any
sort of refuse from any sort of animal
or eat any refuse from any sort of
animal okay let's just agree upon that
all right modern medicine has replaced
any sort of traditional remedies
all right well this is interesting
because the scholars approached um
the prophetic or the prophet mohammed
speech on the standards of or
understanding of medicine and matters in
the dunya in in various ways so there's
also a hadith inside
muslim where he's passing a group of
gate farmers i don't know if you're
familiar with this hadith and uh he
tells the date farmers you guys should
sort of manually pollinate these these
day these date trees uh you know through
some sort of method and uh they kind of
disagree they kind of were skeptical
first they said okay we'll do it because
you know you're the prophet so we'll
we'll we'll we'll uh pollinate these day
trees all right
and uh so they didn't they didn't have a
very good yield that year it was
actually a bad deal so we caught a
profit told you we're not done
so um then they came to the problem they
complained they said you told us to do
this and look what happened our farm
didn't turn out very nice and the
prophet because you don't have said
something very very clear and very
specific today he said look when i say
something from a religious perspective
you take it as absolutely
the other stuff is my opinion
he literally said this this is
this is a sunny baby okay
um so a lot of scholars interpreted from
this that when it came to religious
matters specifically or what he said he
was speaking on behalf of allah or if he
was giving some sort of inspiration that
of course has had to be accepted
all the time but when it came to other
matters like whether it be architecture
or military uh strategy etc etc it was
really his personal opinion and it
wasn't it had no um
what is it uh
impact upon his problem
okay there are even many times in the
theater where he he received advice from
his companions and during war time
during battles and things like this so
in that respect
uh the reason i bring this up
is if this bothers you
if you're saying well the prophet's not
good with medicine
then well who cares
because the many of the skulls himself
said well that's not what makes him a
prophet so
let me just say that you shouldn't have
that concern to begin with now another
uh school of thought or other
interpretations hadith that was very
specific situation to those individuals
okay so it did work for those people but
it's not to be universalized
so for example he said only for those
particular travelers that that worked
and it was a matter of allah inspiring
him just for those particular people and
some sort of i don't know that urine had
somehow some chemical properties that
helped cure their their illness at the
time
uh of course that's not even the point
of the hadith idea there's supposed to
be another message behind it but
so those are the two approaches you can
take so if you're really worried about
these sort of things
let me just be clear again
once again his infallibility has nothing
to do with his worldly knowledge
it never did
there are some there are a lot of
muslims today who think it does and
that's causing a lot of problems in the
muslim world
okay because uh
the prophet was only prophetic in the
sense that allah
gave him particular knowledge
but if allah didn't give him scientific
knowledge
then why are you concerned about when he
says things regarding science or
medicine or whatever
okay
that's that's really how we should be
approaching it shouldn't be any concern
if you're concerned about camel you're
in if that's the basis of whether you
leave islam or not or you still stay
with the song then you have more
problems than that
because there's a lot in islam that has
it has
if that's what you're searching for then
i'd say that there's something else
wrong
because i i don't i personally don't
understand why that's an issue
wait would you drink pamela you're in no
i would not not usually
sometimes
next question yeah i have another
challenge for you go ahead okay so
the prophet he said he went on the
israel
so
he said that he
went on
he went on a unicorn up to the seven
heavens and he
uh met everyone and
people who were dead and then he said he
came back all right so what was that
about
what's uniform
i mean it's a unicorn it doesn't have
wings i don't understand this whole
flying horse thing you know um i i don't
think it's even referred to as a flying
horse in the united states right it's
referred to as a creature specifically
made by a law you know i find this
really fascinating it's like all these
we have all this technology now where we
have rockets that can go into space and
things like this and we think about like
traveling to distant universes and we
think that's perfectly rational but
allah makes a creature that can go to
heaven all of a sudden it's a big deal
like you're talking about the omnipotent
creator of all existence
you know
[Music]
why not you know if you want to be a
unicorn sure i don't care but you know i
don't think that's the description
um anyway so
i think abu bakr gave the the best
response to this when he was asked about
this um somebody approached him and they
asked him when the prophet peace be upon
him had mentioned
that this occurred his companions
believed him immediately and somebody
was kind of skeptical they came up and
said john the bucket and said why did
you do you really believe that this
happened same question as you're giving
me right now
and everyone can get a very beautiful
response he said i believe something
even more extraordinary than this
i believe that he is a prophet from
allah
and what's fascinating about that
response is that it actually tells us a
lot about how we're supposed to
understand reality not just religion but
reality in general
um today we live in a very
i wouldn't say scientific society
actually that's an incorrect way of
putting it because most people are
ignorant of science
we claim to be scientific people but our
understanding of science is invisible
abysmal just horrendous horrible just
you know just nonsense
which is very bad
um so
you know we claim to be assigned in
society but most people don't really
understand what science is how it
operates you know we have a very
absolutist understanding of scientific
uh knowledge you know we think
everything is coming from a scientific
journal is absolute fact
uh you know we read something in time
magazine or something oh view a
scientific discovery says that drinking
wine can be healthy for you at times two
years later drinking wine is poisonous
you should not drink it anymore that's
actually happened recently i don't know
if you saw that a recent report came out
saying you've been drinking a little bit
of wine is not a really good idea um
i'm not saying that they're that i'm not
talking about science but i'm a big
science enthusiast one of my especially
philosophy of science
but
you know we live in the society where we
want all of these proofs you know from a
scientific perspective but in reality
humanity doesn't act that way you don't
believe that
in fact even though you're saying
science is not believing that right
um
so
what i mean to say is like let's say for
example uh who in here believes in
morality
let me answer the idea yeah can you give
me a scientific peer-reviewed paper that
proves the existence of morality
okay how about human rights
does that exist
do rights exist do people have rights
why
i don't see any scientific evidence for
that
how about political theories
how about values how about purpose
how about art and beauty how about
everything that makes you a human being
90 of the things that you and i believe
in on a daily basis that makes us
function in the world as people
has no scientific basis
amazing
you know
and yet we're still here wow
how do we know that he wasn't dreaming
how do you know he's well let me guess
that
what i'm trying to get to is that
certain beliefs that we hold especially
with the religion or even outside of
other ideas you know are based not on
direct evidence that that thing is the
case
most of you in here
actually all of you here let me just let
me just say i've never seen that the
earth is wrapped
we haven't
so it is flat
but you believe it because why because
the data for what is being told to you
seems coherent to your experience and
that's really how we believe things we
believe it based on coherency
so for example we do most of things we
believe are not directly empirically
observable so in the case of abu bakr
that's actually what he was affirming
there is that sort of understanding of
epistemology or theory of knowledge
in that people it was so easy for him to
believe that that occurred because he
already believed something else
that made that rational
do you understand there was a
foundational belief that he had he
already believed based on other reasons
that the prophet
was a prophet and that allah would have
could give him this but it wasn't like
extraordinary for him in the least
how is that extraordinary this guy is
talking to god
like
you know of course he probably went up
to heaven it's not a big deal you know
what i mean that's nothing
of course he made a unicorn
or some sort of creature i you know you
believe in allah you believe that
he's the prophet of allah why not that's
not an extraordinary belief it's only
extraordinary to people who already deny
those foundations
so like when you're talking to an
atheist for example
they're gonna laugh about this be like
oh you believe in this that he went up
to the heavens and stuff it's like yeah
i do and they laugh at you but the
reason they're laughing is not because
what you think is actually ridiculous
the reason they're laughing is because
they already think the foundational
beliefs that make that rational are
ridiculous so when you want to convince
an atheist by the way you should never
start with this stuff
you first need to convince them that god
exists
and that the prophet is the prophet then
this stuff doesn't
enter their minds
it's not it's not nonsensical our
background beliefs are what make
something look rational or not rational
okay
yes sir yes no i was just gonna ask the
background belief for human rights for
human rights humanism
well but rights themselves i mean sorry
to grow a little bit of a quick tangent
rights themselves natural rights came
prior to humanism like individuals such
as thomas aquinas within the christian
tradition catholic came up with a
concept of death well he didn't come up
with it but he elucidated them further
from aristotelian philosophy
who had uh individuals even within the
islamic church even given
who talked about natural rights so in
fact natural rights have a very theistic
or people who believe in god uh
background behind that humanism sort of
took from that
and uh
hasn't really provided what i consider
to be a proper metaphysical foundation
for what rights are
but that's a completely different
discussion
sorry yeah i got another one yeah
why did the prophet muhammed
so why did he buy and sell slaves okay
isn't that isn't it
[Applause]
buying and selling slaves even like it's
a very controversial subject even
professor brown got in trouble for this
a couple of months ago uh he was giving
a academic lecture on the nature of
slavery
some islamic folks came out completely
he contextualized his comments to make
him seem like he wants to have slaves
and we had to go through a long period
of trying to remarket
him and
you know attack these uh these erroneous
claims
he's now since uh recovered from that
you know slander and he went on to write
a 400 page book on slavery
which he completed in three months
professor brown is a workaholic
anyways so
um
this is going to be a long answer
uh because i need to kind of
go into some details same one with the
aisha one
but uh
i have to ask you guys a question first
and you get a problem
okay
what is immoral about ownership
that's the first thing i'm not going to
i'm not trying to justify them i just
want to ask that question
what is immoral about ownership
per se yes
it makes one human being seem
less
have less rights than another less
rights and other people well in fact the
okay so let me define ownership first it
just means to have control
over an individual that's it
okay that's the general
definition now how that's manifested
itself throughout time
with regard to human beings has been
called slavery okay
and uh there are some individuals for
example in this in this in this room who
have or everyone actually who has a
particular image of what slavery is
okay especially if you come from
literally ethnicity
or particular cultural background you're
going to understand that slavery in a
very negative negative sense and you
have every right to do so because it was
immoral
that said there have been other
manifestations of this institution that
do not mimic anything in your mind
whatsoever
literally like i'm i'm not even joking
uh so we don't even talk about
islamically okay by the way i haven't
given my answer yet i'm just still
trying to give you some background all
right
um
so uh
many cultures
have practiced it in different ways so
even europeans had a form of slavery uh
that was more like certain what they
call indentured servitude
um which was nothing like what we call
chattel slavery today
so um i just so the reason i said all
that is because i want to give
background that there are various
manifestations of this
and that not all of them were
necessarily loaded with certain
negativities
and that they were practiced for various
reasons okay so that's a concise
background
moving into this
uh when the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him was given his mission he
entered a world where
the institution of slavery was global
it was a natural
institution within society everywhere so
why didn't he abolish it
so within islamic theology and islamic
law
uh one of the greatest things that you
can do not only for the remission of
your own sins but also for just gaining
benefits in the
afterlife is to free a slave
okay so the prophet peace be upon him
already came with these injunctions
to free slaves now as to why the entire
institution was not abolished
there are certain reasons for that now
in islam it neither condones no outright
condemns the institution
uh they're just hints behind the fact
that there are negativities to be
enslaved
okay which is why we had some certain
laws where it was allowed to free them
in order to you know compensate for
something or to for the remission of
your sins
so it's implied that there's something
negative about it so the reason that the
prophet peace be upon his companions
had slaves and still practice that
institution
generally speaking was because
uh many uh scholars have come to the
conclusion logical conclusion that
to abolish the entire practice
at one time would cause massive
massive chaos
uh in the society in which it was
practiced
so
and what i mean by that is not just
economic chaos but in terms of the
slaves themselves
not having any position in society not
being able to
even take care of themselves
whatsoever
this and it's also would have destroyed
another part of the institution that a
lot of people don't talk about
um
so to give you another background to
this uh uh prison system is a relatively
new concept
i don't know if you realize this but the
contemporary prison system that we have
is relatively new
prior to prison
slavery was an option
that's that was prison for a lot of
cultures that could not have that
particular institution okay that was
their form of prison was to enslave
people and keep them in bondage
just to make sure that they and they
would give back to society and sort of
do their own work okay and eventually
either be released or whatever through
their own ethic
all right
so uh that was a form of prison for them
to keep prisoners
you know bound in some way and if you
don't if you let these people go they're
gonna come back and fight you so you're
either gonna kill them or
take them somehow right so they didn't
really have anything other you know you
can't make these huge concrete buildings
and
you know start getting people to pay
taxes and stuff in the middle of the
desert
yeah leave them there uh we can talk
about the morality of prison later i
agree with you with your sentiment there
but anyways
actually prison to me is a form of
slavery today
okay whether you consider it just or not
as a different question
but it is in my opinion based on the
very if you contextualize it in the way
that slavery has been practiced in the
past
prison is a form of slavery there are
even work prisons there are people
behind bars
working in a prison for the state
i don't know if you want to i don't know
how you don't call that slavery but okay
um
so uh of course people will argue well
there's purchase and other things like
this but we can discuss that later as
well so anyways back to the whole
content so
having destroyed this establishment
immediately
would have caused men's problems for
that society and for society in general
so a lot of scholars today claim that
the prophet peace be upon him was a
gradual abolitionist basically he put in
certain rules and regulations where it
was a positive thing to free people and
at the same time you put in regulations
to treat your slaves properly
as individuals as people who deserve
rights so for example for example um he
said that you know whatever your master
eats the slave has to eat as well but if
the master wears the slave also has to
to wear so he wanted to equalize them to
the extent where then um the slave was
not treated in the same context as we
understand slavery do you understand so
it is it only became a legal institution
in the sense that that person was
considered owned
but
at the same time they could not be
abused like for instance you're not
allowed to slap your slave
because if you slap them across the face
then they can be freed
you're not allowed to rape your slave
you know do a lot of things to yourself
so
how we can compare this to what for
example the american institution of
slavery only a couple hundred years ago
or even a hundred hundred something
years ago
is i think uh a miscategorization
so i would say to be to be frank just to
be inconcise here islam is actually
opposed to slavery but it did not
it did not immediately abolish it as a
result of the fact that the conditions
that would
that it would have purdue will be
you will be killed and your women
control enslaved or
you can convert
remember that passage in the quran there
is no compulsion
they were being judged by their own laws
so they had two options they could
either be judged by their own laws which
they believed it
or they could couple steps and escape
that fate
they all decided to follow their own
laws
so all of the men
were killed
and their women and children were taken
based upon their own ethical standards
there's no compulsion in religion
so can you explain why uh
people tend to use this as
uh
as like you can't force someone to
convert or you can't force someone to
um rule by islamic law right yeah so
these people they rather than choosing
islamic law
they chose their own oh that was the
default
that was their own balls that's what
they wanted if they thought they were
absurd then why did they follow them
they sealed their own faith
[Music]
so so the prophet didn't force them to
rely on their own scriptures that's what
forced them to abide by their own laws
okay
so
they could violate them if they wanted
to
okay
that's why they were given the option
they were told look begin to become
muslim and then we can just
get all this happen
or we can judge you based on your own
laws
what do you want to do
i can't just leave you alone
because you're probably going to kill me
again they're trying to kill me and my
family and all the people that i love
or we can take care of this right here
now
so what do you want
if you want to
because i know you're not going to
to conform to this treaty so it's either
going to be a
you become muslim
and we can trust you
or
b
we judge you based on your own legal
regulations which you agreed to by the
way in the treaty that we wouldn't
impose our laws upon you that we would
only judge you based on your own laws so
what do you want
by the way people i know it's eight
o'clock we're gonna run till 8 30. so
you're probably also wondering okay well
what other options were there tell me
what other options were there
okay what happened when they left them
uh
they sent armies over to start
slaughtering muslims
we're not talking this is about the
united nations everyone this is this is
these are tribal politics
these people were willing to slaughter
you in your entire like your entire
tribe
if you didn't do anything
okay now let me ask you what's more fair
let's say in contemporary context
say that i that i uh i'm allied with
we're out like elimination okay
and that nation decides hey
i'm going to invade
i'm going to break the treaty here at
war with somebody i'm going to come in
i'm going to start i want to kill
innocent people and stuff you can win so
many chances okay now i could just go
over there and
just completely destroy their nation and
like obliterate and force them all to
convert and all this other stuff to make
sure they know
there's nothing to worry about maybe
massacre every single one of them
okay or
i could be fair
i could say then look what do you want
here's my emissary you tell me who
should judge the prophet judge or should
this guy change
this guy's a former troop he knows your
own laws you pick
then they pick that guy
what
what am i supposed to do
i gave you the option
i told you you can either go by my laws
but then you have to become muslim to do
so
or you go by your own laws
which do you prefer
is that fair
or unfair i'd say it's pretty fair
considering the circumstances
i'm willing to give you a chance i'm
willing to let all of this go
if you follow my laws and stop breaking
all these treaties and stuff because
it's the only way that i can guarantee
you're not going to do it
or
you want to follow your laws so badly
okay
which do you prefer
well the quran is in science
what
so in
number two verse number
it says that in debts
the ruling is to have either two men
witness a
financial transaction
or to have one man and two women
okay so
does this imply that women are less
trustworthy or less competent in general
yeah
what
so you just mentioned the specific
context here of that particular passage
that has to reveal this particular
context with regard to
um
women at the time were not normatively
part of the business
felicia was an exception
and other women around here were very
much in exceptions rule ahead of time
so
the that particular ruling was revealed
in respect to
those business transactions
or market transactions in general
that said there's an idea that's that
seems to be more explicit than that
you mentioned it
uh which i'd like to discuss in more
detail
because i think that's more of a problem
then he passed by the women and said oh
women give alms
like give charity as i have seen that
the majority of the dwellers of hellfire
were you women they asked why is this so
o allah's apostle they replied you curse
frequently and are ungrateful to your
husbands
i have not seen anyone more deficient in
reason and religion than you
a cautious sensible man could be led
astray by some of you
the woman asked oh allah's apostle
what is deficient in her reason and
religion he says
it's not the evidence of two women equal
to the witness of one man
they replied affirmative he said
this is deficient this is the deficiency
in her reason
isn't it true that a woman can either
pray nor fast during her menses
the woman replied to the affirmative he
said
this is the deficiency in her religion
so first
off a lot of people love this hadith
like a lot of mexicans
love the study because it seems to
generalize all of them
and what's interesting about that
is that
it's actually
and i'm not blaming the translation
necessarily i just want to be very clear
about certain words
um it's not it's actually very general
at all so for example that had the
interventions uh
when i was talking to these women
he says uh he says can you repeat the
first response
he passed by the woman and said oh we
can give arms as i have seen in the
majority of the voters of how high were
you women okay so the majority of
welders of health are for few women but
the the word women is not in the
narrative
it's just not there it's in parentheses
in all the translations
so it acts as though you is referring to
the gender
women or the sex woman but if you if the
character is just you
so he passed by these women
and he said the majority of the people
in hellfire
are you
okay so he's talking about
not their
their gender he's talking about specific
attributes that they have
so those particular types of women
um he goes on to mention the deficiency
in their intelligence he didn't say
intelligence it says read
reasoning
which means just being able to
rationalize specific things
so it's not it doesn't mean you're iq
that the idea has nothing to do with
your intelligence
okay so it has to do with your ability
to
to understand the particular thing is
the comprehensive particular thing so
this is in reference to the w markets
and things like that
so he said you're deficient in that
sense and then he goes on to say
division because of the medicine things
like this right so he's specific he's
talking specifically about these
particular women that were in the mark
or that were in the around the masjid
which is also near the marketplace by
the way
who
[Music]
had particular traits regarding how they
treated their husbands
because notice how he's very specific
there he says notice how you treat your
husband's like you are very ungrateful
obviously not every woman on the planet
okay so he's talking about these
particular women so like i said once
again when he says you
it's not their gender it's specified
you're specifying a certain subgroup
within that
larger
identity okay so that this hadith always
gets taken out of context because
you is is assumed to be the universal
declaration for all women which is
nonsense that's not the case and we know
this too based on the practices the
practice of the companions themselves
after the prophet and even also the
problem but let's let's mention one
particular
uh he had a woman
overseeing the market
older elderly woman overseeing the
market
as the person who educated between
uh
sellers and buyers so if there was a
problem in the market this woman i'm not
here exactly
sorry so i i
i looked up later
to oversee the matters in the
marketplace
so she's an exception to the rule right
if it was all about all women then why
would she even be in that position to
begin with
and likewise because
was also
what we consider to be the most
literalistic
of
michaela so why would he
he knew about this hadith right he knew
what the prophet said right it was all
about why would you put this woman as
the as the head of the marketplace
right
so
that was very specific
very specific
um and then this is not even apologetics
or anything like that you can look this
up classical scholars have noticed
this is not quite uh it's not all women
so regarding the two witnesses too
let's look at thick
or even
let's look at the quran when a woman is
accused of adultery by her husband
does she require another woman
to oppose him
there is a specific instance
before unmentioned okay when if a
husband suspects his wife committing
zinna
he can go through the authorities and my
wife communism but if she says i didn't
do it
and they can't do anything
so if
it requires two women to be witnesses
if the valuable woman's testimony was
really half of a man's
why does her testimony cancel out for
husbands
[Music]
thank you i appreciate it
also
in cases of rape scholars are very
explicit about this as well do you need
witnesses to prove rape
why a woman comes and says she's been
raped shouldn't she need to
another woman next to her to remind her
that she was raped
makes no sense
right what does she remind him what is
she being reminded of
specific context related to the
marketplace related to a non
something that was not normative for
women back in the
period of time
that rolling is very specific
because if it was true across the board
why is that beyonce that a woman's
testimony by herself is sufficient in
other areas
it makes no sense
yes
what about the second half of the hadith
that referred to specific
characteristics of women rather than
women of their own attributes such as
being like ungrateful to husbands
because it mentions them not being able
to pray or fast when they're on there
so
how does that join
is a himself
to them
so the first quality that's mentioned is
their ungratefulness that's what he's
attacking them for then they asked him a
question they asked him how are we
deficient
or lacking the actual word is lacking
here in these respects
and then he gives them evidence
from the from the quran in this regard
but the evidence itself what's being
used to justify the statement
that they're lacking
it's not connected to
the first
judgment does that make sense the recent
third helped by it
is not because of necessarily the
deficiency or the lacking thereof the
reason they're helping because he makes
them clear is because of their
behavior towards their husbands
that's what he was specifically
referencing
as the reason why they were being
punished
so that other part the other half is
actually a different almost a different
kind of different discussion but a
different part of the discussion
does that make
some sense or
yes but still the reasons for them being
lacking are now universally applicable
to half of
that's for any woman let me ask you a
question sorry okay let's say i have a
company
i walk in i see my employees right
and i i say to
them guys are all you know are all gonna
be fired
okay all of you
every man in here is everybody you men
have been fired
because you don't do your jobs
all right
you don't do your job real lazy okay
and um
then you tell me okay uh and i say
something about you lacking initiative
right so you say well how do we lack
initiative
and i say you like initiative you men
men you lack initiative
because of paid and because of being
right say something like oh you know you
don't get up on time you men don't get
up on time
and you men don't do this you men don't
do this
all right
now
is that statement itself
okay
does that necessarily
apply
to
every man on planet earth now
i understand what you're about to
respond with by the way because you're
saying well women commences and things
like this right
but is that quality
is it for on itself say that these women
are lacking because of those
things
or is the problem saying that they are
specifically lacking
because of these things
do you see what i'm you see the
distinction
you don't see the same thing okay does
the quran itself say that women are
lacking
in their religious faith
because they have medicines
no
the prophet is telling them they are
lacking
because of their menses okay that
they're lacking in their religious
in some way in religion because of their
menses
in what way is he telling them that like
do you understand what i'm what i'm
trying to get out here
it sounds like it's very semantic it's
not selective it sounds like it's
maybe i'm not understanding the full
picture of it okay so
if i'm trying to make a rejoinder or if
i'm trying to count you for something
say if you're arrogant and you're and
you're i'm not saying i'm just saying
you know that somebody's like these
women are ungrateful to their husbands
and they think they're all hot and
everything like this they think that
they're the best
right i'm not saying hot physically i'm
just saying that this awesome stuff
right and i come at you and say guess
what you're lacking
okay
you're lacking in your religion and your
reasoning because of these reasons so
don't think that you are
the greatest thing that there is is that
lacking necessarily
me trying to say that women are somehow
lower
or am i saying i'm trying to remind
those people that you aren't everything
that you think that you are here are
some things that you are limited with
with respect to
your position
do you see what i'm it's not he's not
trying to insult a bit
do you know what i'm trying to say does
that make some sense i'm trying to give
you a common example with the employee a
bit
i tried i don't know if that was a
proper analogy either but
the lacking is not meant to be an insult
okay because we don't consider a woman
who has her menses to be less religious
than a man before andre specifically
says that a man and a woman can both buy
for righteousness
they're equal in that sense
so this is this is not the problem
contradicting that statement he's
telling them specifically like do not
think yourself higher than your husbands
you do not have this
and you do not have this
is that
really i know it makes sense so it does
make a little bit more sense it's it's
the tone is not being expressed in the
hadith
that's the problem
the tone is not being expressed
explicitly
all right
um
i'm trying to find a better way to make
me say that you guys are like
however
how many people get it okay hands up if
you guys get it
well that's even men getting off so
that's
obviously the menu right so but the
women are like huh
it's not going to pass with me right
so are you saying that they were he was
he was trying to bring them down a notch
he was trying to make them by
saying that you're just reminding them
what they know
they don't necessarily possess in
comparison to
their husband he was actually doing that
because those two things are only in
contrast to
men
to those men okay so we're gonna you
can't pray all the time
because we have your menses
okay then whereas your husbands are
praying all the time
all right
your husbands run the businesses
whereas your testimony in this respect
is deficient
do you understand so you're not the best
that was he was trying to bring them to
the same level because they were
ungrateful to their husbands they were
looking down on their husbands
you understand that he was trying to
contrast
trying to say that look you are not
better
than them
right you
have limitations like they do
okay do not sit here and look down upon
your husbands
they thought they were better than them
yes that's why they were trying to bring
them down yes that's what he was trying
to do
okay does that make sense
it was hard for me to convey because
there's a tone there that's being
expressed
there's a there's a specific tone
okay
he's passing these specific women he
didn't just go you know
you are deficient
okay
that's not what he did
he was talking to those girls
because they needed to be reviewed
for their behavior he knew that they
were they were degrading their husbands
all right that's how bad it was there
are other specific instances in this
respect as well and other ideas where it
talks about certain women from 4-h were
very disrespectful towards their
husbands and the problems be upon him
had to read had to remind them of
certain things about who their husbands
were in comparison to them so there are
some cases where he actually references
his other husband's strength physically
he says remember
they can't do something to you but they
could
so please
treat them with you know the same
respect as they try to treat you with
and he was kind of warning them like
look they don't have to be like this
okay they're doing this because of islam
they're doing this because of their
values and stuff so you know have some
respect for them as they have respect
for you you know don't don't demean them
and think that they're weak because
they're being restricted from doing
things
remember what happened prior to islam
they were burying you alive
so
show some respects for weaker husbands
are now
you know what i'm trying that's that's
some of the things that he would say to
some of these women because when islam
came not all the women but served the
women took this as an event took
advantage of this
to to kind of not do revenge but kind of
to
to over to lord over their husbands like
oh you can't beat me
you can't do this to me you can't
divorce me when you like you know for no
uh um
like you can't abuse me basically and
take advantage of me you can't so i'm
not going to do this to you because i
know you can't retract you can't fight
me back
and so the prophet had to come and say
look
remember where you used to be
and who this man used to be
don't overstep your values
does that make sense
so that's what he was trying to
level the playing field as it were
okay isn't it true that when muslims
blew themselves up
they get
72 virgins in heaven
is
[Music]
can we say like is it misogynistic or
something is that is that probably what
we're conferring here
that is it's wrong for men to have i
think it's the
suicide itself suicide
themselves okay
let's just deal with the issue
all right we can give this visit this is
later but anyway
so the quran is is really beautiful in
the sense that when it talks about what
people want to achieve in the afterlife
it always expresses it in the most
uh
abundant ways so like you're gonna get
this many truths you're gonna get this
many houses you're gonna get this many
distances and they're gonna be huge and
beautiful without any consequences etc
so
you know it's interesting that a lot of
times the brawn emphasizes to men who
fight the battle back the number one
thing the one thing that the first thing
that they're going to get are urgent
okay and a lot of people look at this
and they're like that's disgusting
that's you know patriarchal and nonsense
but i want you to think about it from
the context of a seventh-century arab
an arab muslim
male
okay
the most valuable thing to have
for a muslim man
is a righteous spouse
now imagine that multiplying
for them virginity was not necessarily
about sex it was a state a label of
chastity a purity of uh
belonging to only one person
it's like this is this is mine
right nobody nobody else has
this is only meant for me
and in multiple so the quran
the prophet others are trying to
emphasize that the quantity
of that which you desire the most in
life
will be there
okay and the one thing that men desired
most muslim men was not because they
just wanted to have sex all the time and
everything you know these horrible
things that we talk about companions
we always emphasize that they're these
sexual monsters
all they care about is women you know
no
because the most valuable thing to a
muslim
is
the conscious woman
that is the most emphasized thing the
one thing that you can treasure more
than anything else in your existence as
a muslim man
is to have a righteous
spouse and righteous children righteous
things like this not material items
those were emphasized after this
they were emphasized that having all
these palm trees and all these running
rivers and things like this
right these were emphasized after that
but they were not in the same category
they're not material objects
some of these have objections no no no i
want to be very clear because people
will have this really messed up
mentality that the reason that they
mention women is that just because of
sex like that's all men care about i'm
sorry that's that's degrading
demand
how many very clear that's very
degrading to men
there are scientific studies today that
when a man loses a wife or he or he
breaks up men take it harder than women
do
that's why the male suicide rate is
higher
okay when a man finds a woman that he
cares about he loves needs a wouldn't
give himself up to
that takes up most of his existence
a man does not work because he likes big
houses in cars the man works for the
most part because he wants to give it
all to his family
a man is willing to run in front of a
bus and to protect his wife or his kids
not because he oh i like doing this
you know i don't i don't
get up every morning and go to work
because i like to work
i get any more extent i pay the bills
why because my wife
needs to be taken care of
my i take i might look at a cardboard
box
but i don't
a lot of things that i have
that i give to my family a lot of things
that men work for generally like most of
their income goes to their family
a man dedicates his life to his family
who has
immigrant parents here i'm sure many of
you do
but have you seen how your father does
everyone has different situations but
most of you have you seen how your
parents your father because of your
father i know people a lot of the young
men who tell me about their fathers who
would literally they'll have degrees
over in some other country they come
over here and drive a taxi
you know for years and years they work
like
endless hours
just to make sure that their wife and
their kids are happy they sacrifice
every part of their being when a man
loves a woman
there is nothing else he will give
anything else
that becomes his life
okay
just the same as when a woman has a
child
all right that everything is given to
them to that child all right
men take heartbreak and they take
um
companionship
deeply deeply personally
yes men can be all you know think about
sex all the time because psychologically
we've proven this okay but when a man
dedicates himself to a woman
there is no better loyalty
as far as i'm concerned i'm a man i know
i understand okay but even in the animal
kingdom you know
among mammals males will sacrifice
themselves instantly to protect
everything
they don't care about their own lives
so when a man martyrs himself for the
sake of islam and he's promised
companionship in heaven after he gave up
his family back home
and he goes into the desert for three
four five six months two four five years
to fight against the disbelievers who
were about to invade your land and kill
your family he better get some sort of
promise in the afterlife
something that is going to replace or at
least compliment everything that he gave
up
and when allah tells these men i'm going
to give you righteous spouses
in heaven
you may be 72 virgin men are not right
so
my point once
and look i get it there are some really
horrible math that
there are horrible men out there and
there are sex crazed men and you know
men who go around and rape and do
horrible things
but what about the men
you know who don't do those things what
about the men who emphasized a different
standard and who represent a manifesto
and what are you saying about the
companions we didn't mention this
they were some of the best men on this
earth they treated their wives like this
do you honestly think that they wanted
virgins in heaven because of just
because of sex
because when they were told that that's
what they were thinking oh yeah i'm
gonna have a lot of sex when i get to
heaven
you know it's great that's why i'm
sacrificing my life right now in the
middle of this desert because i want to
have a bunch of sex
honestly
i it just doesn't it doesn't make sense
to me
it doesn't make any sense at all
that you would die for that just for
that
come on we're not we're not machines
like that just want to
do those things and you know we have
feelings too because men
sacrifice so much of what they love and
cared about just to perform those acts
and they died in the middle of a desert
nowhere to be buried nowhere to be
commended for bed their families learned
about their death several months later
oh by the way your husband was killed in
battle
i know you're expecting him back
you know he died for you by the way
allow me to reward him
you don't think about it from that
angle no no he's enjoying himself he's
fine
you know i was not in the middle of that
you know
and i was scared for my life i didn't
know if i was coming back to my family
and a lot came down and said look i'm
going to give you all of this
and more
even
too your wife she goes up to heaven she
joins you she becomes clean about all of
them
it's like get all of this you're going
to get all this reward i know you're
scared but look at what you're going to
achieve
trying to calm you down allah is trying
to tell you something like look you
don't have anything with you i
understand what you sacrifice you will
gain everything because how how
comforting would you be you really think
that these soldiers who are fearing for
their lives in that moment were thinking
yeah i'm going to get sex
like i wouldn't enter my mind
that would be the last thing that into
my mind if i was about to die
honestly
i would not be in the mood in that
moment okay
i'm just being frank with you right
could anybody male in here honestly be
in the mood when they're about to face
death
the reason that they were fearful of
them was because their women were all
allocated in one area yeah they're all
women were behind the soldiers so these
men
were about to actually slaughter women
and children
how angry would you be if you knew your
entire family was about to be killed
and you still gave him the choice
if you choose between your law
and we spare your women and children
okay
finally in either case
we could have done the same to you
but we're going to let you choose
yeah now i'm pretty sure they were about
to spawn in their home limited shelter
that was actually discussed that's not
something they decided
it was kind of they were discussed but
they said don't we're not going to do it
but then they said to themselves should
we follow our own laws
and then they said
even though it's going to end this in
this way and they say yes you will never
join them that was basically the
rejoinder so they were so proud
of the fact that they were opposing they
didn't care about their own kids
in fact they weren't willing to kill
themselves because they were cowards but
at the same time they didn't even care
that this was going to happen
okay
they were so proud of that they were
willing to go down the ship
so that was that was a disgusting part
about their leadership i think like when
they were discussing they said
oh
muslims
defeat you and also result if we do
that it will reset
your kids and your children or taking
the slaves from the muslims
so
better just kill them now i guess
it's a thought process
it was it was it was
but it wasn't because they cared about
them
that's the funny thing it's because
there's a fork of humiliation what would
be said about that was said about
themselves they were only concerned
about what happened to their children
and their lives and stuff based on
if they would be humiliated in history
that was their only concern what
happened to them
that's how disgusting
these individuals were
and that's why they were all the male
soldiers not the males the children and
the you know were left alone but all the
men and soldiers were killed because
that was their mentality they didn't
care
you know they were willing to slaughter
man woman and child of the muslim
population they're willing to give up
their own
if necessary you know to save their own
skin
and they didn't the only reason they
cared about them was because it didn't
look good on them
you know that's that that was the
mentality of this tribe that you're
dealing with here
so
i don't know it was extreme situation
but the fact that the prophet actually
allowed them the choice
to decide their own fate is
unheard of in history
like any other nation would have just
completely wiped them off you know
regardless
so that's just something to consider
um anyways can we did everyone get my
explanation
yeah yeah okay are we are we cool now
we're good
that's okay doesn't matter okay
yes sir you're still going to have an
open q a session yeah sure yeah all
right no but like uh the thing is that
formally uh we're done what we're done
now i mean
formally
i think i like this song now oh really
that's good